what in London yeah I live there more
than here I live it's um I live in
Hampstead leafy Hampstead
oh you know yeah that's what I've been
doing the last few months they're doing
warm-ups you are I've done about 50 and
other tour starts it's not already a
plug yeah tour starts in February I'll
do UK and keep going back and forth but
you know between gigs net I want to do
New York in May probably
and then other other parts of America
because there are other parts of America
record I don't know and the rest is just
a bunch of [ __ ] that went familiar with
right exactly right that's where nobody
here understands how Trump won because I
went through brexit so I go on stage and
I go all brexit enough oh yeah people
have got different opinions it's a good
litmus test though yeah it wasn't an
inoculation for me because I live
through brexit and then when this
happened I thought yeah no it was it was
on his way you know we don't mad people
get it yeah you know like if you try to
be funny with an opinion and that it's
not their opinion they get so angry at
you for having the opinion well that's I
mean I think that was part of why this
happened I think people felt sick of
being told what they can do and think
and and and it just divided into two
camps which isn't there's a thousand
camps you know right and that but they
divided it into two you know four
against liberal elite or fascist and
it's like it's it's not that it's do not
I mean it's yeah that's what it came to
and and this was sort of like a reaction
to that I think that there went no no
we've had enough but it's just it's just
weird for like somebody like you to go
from like the Golden Globes where you
were making the Hollywood liberal elite
kind of upset with you because you were
making fun of them and that was a bit of
your reputation to being critical of
Trump which means you are now the
Hollywood liberals it's all mixed up
people people want to know whose side
you're on before they decide what you
said was funny or good all right they
have that they've picked a song
yeah and that's the problem so people
who like Trump will not see any bad and
anything he does if he said himself I
could shoot someone off with having you
and he's right you know
and the other side won't see any good in
what he does because they you know I
mean so it's it's they don't want to
this there's this new thing of winning
is more important than being right right
and it started and it started with
social media it started with political
correctness where people now believe
that they quite rightly believe their
opinion is worth as much as someone
else's opinion but even if your opinion
is worth as much similar this opinion
people now think their opinion is worth
as much as other people's facts it's the
world gone crazy that the alternative
facts what we used to call them lies in
alternate fad anything you don't agree
with that you see well fake news I know
the facts little girls like you said you
were gonna tell me that was an
alternative fact yeah you know yes again
I've sort of seen this happening for
like two or three years on Twitter when
you do get to meet people you wouldn't
normally meet you know unless you went
to a mental home I am Steve Manchin so
but they don't like fact they knows them
I found out when I went on to oh I found
out that atheists are the most hated
group in the world does the people think
atheists there was a there was just
leaving nothing was it for not believing
yeah they were voted least trustworthy
group in America things like that from
Twitter but you mainly find out that um
the average person is is scarily
misinformed